If we ask people which image
they most associatewith love,
there's no question that the valentine
heart would top the list.
But what is this link?
Is it real or purely metaphorical?
As a heart specialist, I'm here
today to tell you
that this link is very real.
Fear and grief, for example, can
cause profound cardiac injury.
The nerves that control unconscious
processes suchas the heartbeat,
can sense distress and trigger a
maladaptive fight or flight response
that triggersblood vessels to constrict,
the heart to gallop and blood pressure to rise,
resulting in damage.
In other words,
it is increasingly clear
that our hearts areextraordinarily
sensitive to our emotional system.